okay let's go to our next caller from
the six-30 area code six-30 what's going
on how are you good who's this okay a
half an hour okay good what's on your
mind today so I would I have a look I
want to congratulate you threw up
Circassian 400,000 subscribers thank you
so I have a question for you do you know
comedian Joe Rogan yes of course I'm
aware of him yeah so we just asked Kyle
and Sam see her about this - and Kyle
just thought so on his 500 of cake Q&A
he told us the story about the time you
know when he was close to going on a
show and there were two reasons why he
was close to going on a show cause like
one of the reasons why it was you know
the sank had his beef with Harris and
Joe strongly sided with with Harris
right and then uh and at that time says
piles like show like didn't have quality
yeah like only a hundred thousand
subscribers at that time okay that we
had come up and he said he'd be glad to
go on a show he invited him and we asked
Sam cedar about this too and he did a
video segment about when he when Joe
Rogan is helping Trump in the
Republicans I don't I don't think he is
really helping him he's just kind of
like he didn't he's not like inviting
look like his cousin you know he's
surrounded by a lot of Hollywood
liberals so but so what's your question
let's see if we can get to that party
huh
I'm gonna ask you a question a second
and Sam cedar said he was close to going
on a show too when he tried to crawl
away and try to see him but it never
happened so I want to ask you questions
so if Joe Rogan works and why do you
want to show you oh yes I would you will
I'd like Jesus but you know I think he
will definitely invite you because you
know you're like not part of the team I
see no work anymore he'll he'll
definitely invite you well listen I'm
waiting for the invitation so if you can
facilitate it I don't know how you can
be so sure but I would love to appear on
the Joe Rogan
program but now did I'm wondered I could
have answered that question the same way
without the lead up you know what I mean
I like to lead up though the leader ways
and you know I was just saying I could
have I could have answered the actual
question of what I go if invited without
the entire preface the preface was
fascinating but I could have gone right
to it but ok thanks so much listen if
you can help facilitate I would be glad
to be on the Joe Rogan program thank you
very much